zurück bei Bild die richtigen Fragen zu
den affenpocken allein dieses Wort das
macht uns Sorge seit einigen Tagen auch
hier in Deutschland nachdem die ersten
Fälle jetzt auch eben in Deutschland
zunächst in München dann in Berlin
bestätigt wurden und hier in Berlin hat
die Senatsverwaltung reagiert auf diese
ersten Fälle mit der Warnung die uns
irgendwie bekannt vorkommt und sie hat
dazu aufgefordert jetzt vorsorglich dann
wenn man Symptome bei sich feststellt
ffp2 Schutzmasken zu tragen was sagt uns
das Herr Frank wir empfinden sie diese
ersten Warnungen also ich wer hat das
noch mal gesagt das kommt von der
Senatsverwaltung hier in Berlin
offiziellen Politik sie ist vollkommen
lebt in der Irrationalität ja Affen
gucken hat mit Aerosol nichts zu tun
ffp2-masken sind ein eine Schutzmaske
für Lackierer für Schleife die sie auch
nur stundenweise aufsetzen dürfen es ist
es zeigt diese völlige Verlust von von
Wirklichkeit der der da aus solchen
Texten spricht die sich einfach nicht
mehr dafür interessiert was eigentlich
das Problem ist und was eine Therapie
ist ob die dann wirksam ist oder ob sie
viel mehr Schaden anrichtet ob sie
überhaupt Sinn macht Herr Rödel spricht
daraus Hilflosigkeit wie Herr Frank sagt
jetzt erstmal ganz schnell am Wochenende
zwei Fälle in Berlin dazu auffordern
Schutzmasken zu tragen wenn man Symptome
bei sich feststellt
also bei den affenpokern denke ich ist
die Maske nicht geeignet diese
Empfehlung hätte ich nicht gegeben ich
denke da haben wir ja eben darüber
gesprochen wie sich also das Virus hier
überträgt und
wie man auf so eine Idee kommen kann
kann ich jetzt nicht nachvollziehen gib
meine Hilfe wie man auf so eine Idee
kommt weil diese Maschine eben jetzt
vorhanden ist weil man das erprobt hat
jetzt über zweieinhalb Jahre das
bedeutet ist es im Moment auszuschließen
also so schrecklich das klingt aber dass
wir jetzt bald über Affen Pocken
lockdowns reden hier in Deutschland
also ich halte das für ausgeschlossen
ich wir müssen wie ich am Anfang gesagt
habe prüfen ob sich die Übertragungswege
verändern nachdem was ich bis jetzt
wahrgenommen habe
ist der Übertragungsweg ein ganz anderer
es lässt sich also in dem Sinne kein
direkter Vergleich mit dem Coronavirus
herstellen außerdem muss man ja auch
wissen dass also eigentlich alle die
über 50 sind
gegen Pocken geimpft sind und damit also
einen Schutz haben wollen wir einmal
kurz in der Runde den Test machen hier
Herr rüttelt sie sind also gegen darf
ich das sagen gegen Pocken geimpft dann
ja in der Runde Herr Trabert sind sie
geimpft gegen Pocken her Fragen ich habe
da so eine Narbe ich gehe davon aus dass
die davon das heißt sie sind so
skeptisch gegenüber jetzt der
corona-impfung damals aber noch dann in
ihrer Jugend oder Kindheit
wahrscheinlich in der Kindheit
man kann gar nicht oft genug wiederholen
um was es eigentlich geht es geht darum
dass wir in Deutschland und wir in
anderen westlichen Ländern Standards
entwickelt haben um zu schnelle
Zulassungen zu verhindern Stichwort aber
auch aus ihrer Sicht ausreichend
zugelassen damals sie konnten glaube ich
nicht unbedingt ja da gibt es ja auch
schon auch impfopfer aus der Zeit ich
kenne aber keine Zahlen aber wir haben
eben aus der Erfahrung also ich bitte
jetzt nicht das Impfen so in Frage zu
stellen
ist was ganz tolles und wie gesagt ich
denke in bei Corona hat das auch mehr
vielen Menschen das Leben gerettet ich
will noch ein Punkt ist mir noch mal
wichtig weil wir jetzt wieder
Homosexualität schwule es darf nicht
dazu führen dass hier wieder eine
Personengruppe diskriminiert wird das
ist mir zu sehr im Fokus ja sie werden
so und so schon von unserem Staat
diskriminiert denken wir an an
blutspendebedingungen das ist eine
brutale Diskriminierung von Menschen die
homosexuell sind also das darf bitte
nicht sein und ich bin auch nicht jetzt
wirklich also das ist mir manchmal zu
undifferenziert ja ffp2-masken machen
auch sind nicht bei Affen Pocken aber
wenn jetzt wieder sowas nein ja
sagt der Trabert nur deswegen reden wir
darüber
generell ist heißt nee das macht ja so
und so übrigens
ganz speziell gesprochen und haben uns
ehrlich gesagt am Wochenende über diese
Warnung ein bisschen gewundert von der
Berliner Politik das wollten wir an der
Stelle diskutiert wissen aber lassen Sie
uns beim Thema Impfen bleiben das ist
doch ein wichtiger Punkt Herr Rödel wie
wir mit dem Thema Impfen jetzt mit Blick
auf Pocken umgehen also in der
Vergangenheit gab es die Verpflichtung
dann ist das irgendwann aufgehoben
worden als ich noch sehr klein war und
sie auch ziemlich klein waren und
mittlerweile diskutiert man aber wieder
darüber dazu zurückzukehren würden sie
sich im Moment dafür aussprechen der
Rödel also werden wir wieder eine Pocken
Impfpflicht erleben in Deutschland
also kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
höchstens dass man eine Empfehlung gibt
für bestimmte Personengruppen die also
sich eher mit Affen Pocken infizieren
können als andere also ich denke hier
ist Prävention gefragt aber keine im
Verpflichtung aber das ist interessant
für wen denn dann wer soll sich denn
dann impfen lassen also für wen soll es
eine Mieter nicht geben das läuft gerade
wieder völlig falsch Herr Rödel welche
Gruppen meinen Sie also wir wir haben
eben wahrgenommen dass also besonders
Männer mit häufigen
Wechseln von Geschlechtspartnern am
ehesten betroffen sind das wie sollen
sich dann impfen lassen Herr Trabert
aber dann sind wir genau bei der
Stigmatisierung
das homosexuelle Männer immer häufig
wechselnden Geschlechtsverkehr wer sagt
das ist muss
sagt es sollten sich die impfen lassen
die junge Männer sind schwul sind und
vermehrt Sexualkontakt haben da muss ich
das ja erstmal auf dem Zettel also wir
kommen hier wieder in eine
mittelalterliche Medizin rein die gerade
so irgendwas ausprobiert und probierte
das aus wir haben ist es tut mir leid
wenn ihr mich wiederhole und da muss ich
ihn wirklich widersprechen wir haben
Standards und es geht wir haben gelernt
in der Medizin dass wir mit Medikamenten
auch Menschen umbringen können ja wir
müssen darauf achten dass streiten dass
das muss drauf achten dass ein
eingesetztes Medikament mehr Nutzen
bringt als Schaden und dazu gibt es eben
Mittel da gibt es ordentliche Studien
und so weiter und so fort und da diese
Standards wurden bei der corona-impfung
gebrochen ich rede nicht über Impfungen
speziell sondern dass diese Impfung
zugelassen worden ist obwohl eigentlich
will mir gerade gehört haben gar kann
ich die Notlage dazu da war aber ja
passiert das jetzt passiert das in
diesem Fall jetzt passiert wenn wir
jetzt über Pocken Impfungen sprechen und
dann bestehe ich auch wieder darauf dass
wenn es ist es wunderbar ich Impfung ist
ein Erfolgsgeschichte der Menschheit
aber diese Impfungen müssen ordentlich
geprüft werden so wie es Standard aber
Herr Rödel Großbritannien bestellt jetzt
schon in großem Umfang Pockenimpfstoff
wir wissen die ob das überhaupt darauf
wirkt also wir
haben was Impfstoffe angeht größte
Sicherheit walten lassen und dass wir
bei Corona so schnell einen so guten
Impfstoff oder Impfstoffe hatten das ist
ein Erfolg und hat sicherlich viele
Menschenleben gerettet und wenn man
jetzt Menschen empfiehlt bestimmten
Personengruppen empfiehlt sich darüber
nach Gedanken zu machen ob man sich
nicht
doch lieber impfen lassen soll also auch
gegen Brocken dann denke ich ist das
also Vorsorge des Staates das heißt ja
ist ja keine Impfpflicht sondern eine
Empfehlung dass man sich mit dieser
Frage auseinandersetzt mit seinem Arzt
redet ob es sinnvoll sein könnte aber
ich glaube nicht dass wir noch mal in
Deutschland eine Diskussion bekommen
über impfpflichten über
ein und zwar ab heute dass diese
Einrichtung bezogene Impfpflicht bitte
ausgesetzt werden alle ernst zu
nehmenden Wissenschaftler die ich kenne
sagen man hätte diese Impfung nur für
die Risikogruppen zulassen sollen und
auch nur mit Ängste Begleitung ich bin
mir das ist nochmal es ist ich musste
jetzt darauf bestehen es ist eine
bedingte Zulassung lesen Sie den Text
der bedingten Zulassung
50507/2006 da steht drin nur bei einer
außergewöhnlichen Notsituation und
strengstens überwacht und ich habe die
impfopfer in meiner Praxis die Leute
leiden es sind Tausende in Deutschland
und das sind Leute die von kurvit nicht
bedroht gewesen wären und das ist ein
Skandal wir werden in zehn Jahren in
Geschichte und hier drin stehen haben
dass das hier in Richtung Contergan geht
und das muss aufhören ich glaube wir
reden hier wie im Kaffeekränzchen drüber
und es ist verdammt ernst wirklich
sind sicher und Impfschäden hat es bei
jeder Impfung gegeben und man wird
feststellen können in der Zukunft ob bei
den corona-impfstoffen da eine größere
Häufigkeit die sind doch schon längst da
schauen sind internationale Literatur
und wir reden über eine bedingte
Zulassung ich glaube es ist ihnen selber
wir reden nicht über eine normale
Impfung wir reden über einen Segen dass
also so schnell Impfstoffe da waren und
wir die Pandemie so schnell überwinden
konnten das hat doch mit der Impfung gar
nichts zu tun ich bitte Sie